um it's wonderful louisville's never had
a time like this and
you know
with g i was just always thought he's
one of the best rappers alive so i
wanted to collab with him him being from
the city is such a special bonus and
obviously
a reason to work but um i give him all
the credit in the world for you know
where he's taking it you know he's made
the records and
people feel some sort of conviction from
him that i felt from the start so i
don't take any credit on g's success but
i'm really happy with what we've done
together and going forward i'm sure
we'll do more but i'm very proud of him
100
uh you got to do a leap of record which
is uh obviously i saw that you had
gotten kind of like ran it by her before
it came out cuz that'd be kind of a
random thing to just drop a song named
after and she had no [ __ ] clue yeah i
didn't want a blind side i felt like she
she seems like a um
a sweet person a nice albanian woman
yeah super sweet she confirmed that when
we talked i just wanted to let
just wanted to let her know and see if
she had said i don't like this it
wouldn't have came out i'll tell you
that so i just wanted to run a buyer